let's see how the fighter and the kid
deal with trolls look at what stars deal
with look what the kardashians and these
people deal with poor cards where people
get on ray romano
no okay
well they just ignore now they just
indian ray romano
[Laughter]
yeah now youtube videos
um have uh this [ __ ] great
family little kids and stuff and dad
they sang baba o'reilly it's so [ __ ]
good and they sang like come together
but he turns the comments off you can't
comment on it comments on youtube are
done he's like no comments
so he just puts it up and you got likes
it was so great like 91 dislikes get the
[ __ ] out of here
it was so good yeah it's it's a cool
story
it's a cool story
are you enraged by his sh by uh brandon
shop shoes i'm enraged look every time
we pull up
every time we pull up a fighter in the
kid episode i'm in i'm visually enraged
by at least four things happening i'm
i'm mad at brendan's outfit although to
his credit this might be the least
enraging outfit brendan shobs had on in
a year
uh i'm enraged by brian cowan's body
language it always disturbs me
everything about this disturb also looks
like somebody's been picking up their
drinking a little bit
you notice a little uptick in the
drinking yeah it seems to be three new
bottles every week
the shoes have been uh replaced by
flicker everybody's miserable
interesting i'm with you with freedom of
speech and our abandonment and right so
you have to have that but at a certain
point if it doesn't help anything and
it's just negative i don't know why we
would support that because
your first amendment right is cool but
if it's not if it's going to be
negativity we need to shut that [ __ ]
down i mean this her channel they could
block over the [ __ ] no but he literally
said the first amendment like he brought
up freedom of speech which is like sorry
are you talking about yeah it's a tough
borderline because i'm with you with
freedom of speech
all right all right all right right a
certain point if it doesn't help
anything and it's just negative okay no
hold on sorry i apologize we're not
talking about youtube your channel you
can do whatever you want bandwagon we've
banned people
but we're talking about the first
amendment if it's too much for if it's
too much freedom like what
brennan if it's too much freedom because
like that's the thing i agree with the
youtube comment thing because i think
that there is a huge group of people
like there are people out there that are
just
so [ __ ]
try hard
and so edgy what happened
and then you get [ __ ] banned and then
they go oh freedom what about freedom of
speech and it's like okay but free
speech doesn't apply apply on private
property and it doesn't apply
like like for instance
if roy sounds a taco stand no offense
i'm sorry no that's racist
and then i own a restaurant where
everybody just boils the [ __ ] out of
cabbage and it's terrible right see i
was also racist to myself my
restaurant's better yeah it is clearly
but what if i hired somebody right to
hang out in his restaurant all day and
go you don't want to eat here there's
rats in the kitchen i hear the owner's a
pedophile you know what i mean like
there that doesn't apply like he can go
get the [ __ ] out of my store what is
wrong with you so this this idea that
like freedom of speech like there are a
thousand hate channels about us out
there right
let them do that hey have your channel
but you know do your little we do
commentary [ __ ] on people right we
wouldn't appreciate if we're over here
making fun of them and then they issued
some kind of strike that's [ __ ] now
you're infringing on freedom of speech
right plenty of people out there that
can hate on you make your own channel
whatever but you don't have a right to
stand in the lobby of a place like a
hotel and go that spice has bed bugs it
has bad bugs like eventually the cops
are going to come and go you can't do
this private property sir you can post a
yelp review or a google review you can't
just stand in the lobby and scream at
people i don't know why we would support
that well
when it comes to trolling like they're
they're it shouldn't just be the wild
west no the way you do it is i think
that um
a company that you use so youtube well
we already do this youtube instagram
they're taking a lot of heat for it but
they will censor you if you are
they will take you off youtube i mean
they will take you off if you are
being this insulting right no no they
won't
what no they won't dude
what you know what i can i just say
something can i just say i gotta get one
of the things
that i actually love about brendan chubb
and i love this the brow brand it's
annoying and i know it's going to piss a
lot of people off but one of the things
that really amuses me about brendan
schaub
not that he says [ __ ] that he has no
idea about because everybody in america
does that
he does it
with a level of confidence that i've nev
right like if you and i are commenting
on something we're a little unsure of
you'll hear a little crack in the voice
he
proclaims
absolutely made up [ __ ] on the spot with
the confidence of of a head of state
right like it's just hilarious do we
start listing the people that have been
kicked off of youtube never happened bro
alex jones no didn't happen though he's
not on youtube
didn't happen though dude
people have been taken off youtube isn't
there like terms of service where if you
breach it and you're getting too much of
it people get taken off youtube all the
time
he's so dumb i know people personally by
the
way
like their fifth account because of
comments he's about to admit in this
video too that he never reads youtube
comments so he's about to admit he knows
nothing about what he's talking about i
know people
i guarantee you there's people that are
watching us
right now
right now that are watching us right now
blooptube's on d live why brandon that
have lost their just for comments have
lost their accounts i know people
personally that have lost their youtube
accounts for the comments that they
leave
absolutely they don't it was literally
gloom doom it started with the n-word
then he banned that then it was nick
curse and then it was they banned that
then it was nick gurs and then they
banned that and it was it was becoming
the point where they're writing neek
gears and you're like all right like he
tried his best to police it and then
they still zapped him like they will get
you for your comments yes they will
brendan but if they upload a video
trolling someone but not because
comics got to admit his confidence is
hilarious right he knows he knows
nothing about it he's so stupid he like
honestly you're so stupid
we always [ __ ] on brendan schaub but can
i just pay him a compliment real quick i
got it
the epitome of a guy
i would send into a room to [ __ ]
people
because even if he doesn't know what
he's doing like to reassure some
employees that they're going to get
their checks and stuff brandon shops
your guy because you just tell him and
he's okay great no yeah no it's fine
you're going to get your checks no i
haven't had a check for three weeks no
you did it's there it's at your house
right now like you just with 100
confidence not knowing anything he's no
not going to believe it sorry like it's
just what a dumb man he's the best i'm
turning the corner on brandon shaw i
think i'm starting to like freddie shaw
because nope sorry didn't happen it's
like no the riots are happening right
now no i don't believe you man
sorry dude
well no uh comments too like twitter
twitter when you say certain bad things
i mean what's his name was on yeah
you'll be able to raise
racist stuff or something like that but
if you're just trolling
but it's not he's he's already conceding
like all right well maybe some comments
he's a dumb guy are you implying that
you want youtube to just to delete
people's accounts because they're
trolling so it's not racist stuff
sometimes it's like just
insulting [ __ ] which was what jack
dorsey took so much [ __ ] for because he
runs a huge company there are people
underneath him that were like deeming
some of these things to be well have you
seen like well he doesn't even let brian
finish his points the instagram did so
like jack dorsal was like he was checked
but like he was like doing that stuff
though he's a [ __ ] dolphin
[Laughter]
and put all their uh value on instagram
is you can't see likes anymore right
like you can't wait to see how many
followers that's what i'm saying is that
wasted their ways to you know you that's
a setting brendan i i see likes i like
he's trying no you had you had to go in
there you that's a setting you can have
right on instagram you can hide your
likes and your comments now but you have
to manually go in and do that so brendan
now i don't see i i liked you for a
second brendan but now you're lying
because he's saying no now instagram
i'm sorry department corrected me
instagram instagram instagram uh hides
the comments no they don't that's not a
default setting brendan that is a
setting they created for you and rogan
and santino and tony hinchcliffe and all
these other little babies that [ __ ]
basically that red bar has been
torturing that that was literally made
for these fragile la comedians that were
like man everybody just keeps trolling
man and they gave you an option to
hide the likes and hide the comments now
his pants are tote so tight i don't even
think those are shoes i just think his
feet are turning that color
uh you can still do that again
i thought they kept that oh i thought
but i said it would i said it with the
[ __ ]
unearned confidence of a 20-something
year old woman because that's what he is
he has the unearned confidence of a hot
chick he's a hot chick who never gets
corrected
that's true
um actually these protesters are a
hundred percent justified
if you have to smash an old white lady's
head in with a brick then so be it i
guess huh oh [ __ ]
brendan you're so stupid he's yeah
somebody in the chat actually it's the
word aggressively stupid
[Laughter]
there are there are stage four cancers
that aren't as aggressive as his
stupidity
you know what i mean
he's so stupid it's almost tantamount to
physical violence and how do you dude
look at those
those pants look painted on
what is how does he get those off what
happens if you sweat
they were talking about that right
they took it away from maybe they're
just painted on
he just spray painted his pants on wow
which i thought was brilliant yeah what
i'm saying
whoa oh god jesus christ
he's a genius
that's what you know what else he thinks
is brilliant do you know what else
brendan thinks is brilliant rick and
morty so [ __ ] let's not really
take it with a great assault a law i'm
saying the company itself can create
their own rules
social brandon is can i say i'm sorry
because i just noticed something
brennan is so terrible
that i just noticed the miami vice pants
that brian callan's wearing oh yeah
they're terrible so [ __ ] bad
that i just noticed it brian brian
callan
should never leave this show and here's
why
this is the only time brian callan will
ever be on a show with somebody and
he'll be the good one like he'll be the
less enraging one if you paired brian
callan up with anyone else you'd go god
i [ __ ] hate brian callan he you
better buff you better look theo vaughn
could move on and do better without
[ __ ] brendan a lot of people could
move on and do better without brendan
brian you need to cling to him for life
because i've read your comments before
let me tell you something everybody's on
[ __ ] team ryan they hate brendan job
but if brian calan and theo vaughn did a
show together it would be a totally
different dynamic people would be going
god i [ __ ] hate brian gallon brian
callan
and i figured it out brian calendar
brandon shop this is the brian callan
dresses like the default character you
get when you start gta online and
brandon shop is when you have too much
money you just start buying silly
outfits yeah special rules right which
they do have actually brian just dressed
like nico bellick yeah exactly yeah
you're right he's dressed like a
ukrainian immigrant that would sell you
a [ __ ] fake rolex hey buddy come here
i've got all kinds of rolex with some
kind of carl accent brian callan looks
like he wears ricky gervais
hand-me-downs
[Laughter]
[ __ ] for it too so so in the so now
has the guest said anything no i don't
even know who this guy is who's the
guest
somebody know
is this is this that magical guy we keep
hearing about that
is this how magical i don't know he is
we don't know we don't know who he is
stop
using youtube or instagram because i
can't
well youtube has an automatic they just
wrote an article about this they have an
automatic um
deletion it's an algorithm to leads if
you insult a chinese party with two
particular phrases 50 cent party and
another thing it automatically goes away
not only that this is the other thing
this would be youtube
deletes a lot of comments automatically
because sometimes they go through the
comment not even china in general their
algorithm is set up so a lot of times
people you deleting comments i'm like
i'm not deleting comments youtube's
deleting comments and that's the thing
too it's always it is actually always
like the angry trolls that accuse you of
it because they can't get through they
can't write a paragraph criticizing you
without saying like you [ __ ] jew
zionist [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you know i
mean like they go so hard and then they
go oh what you're deleting my comments
and you're like no youtube is gonna if
you're writing like you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] they haven't i'm not
supporting that they have that algorithm
but they have that algorithm they do and
it deletes your [ __ ] like i i've i have
a policy i don't delete comments i don't
like there's plenty of comments on both
channels i don't like i do delete
comments from people i don't like
that's my workaround and that's my own
business if i don't like you and there's
plenty of people that come in here and
go nurse you're [ __ ] wrong or you
know mercy sound like a [ __ ] today
or this and that would and those people
have been around for [ __ ] years and
they'll be around for years longer i i
ban people i don't like but there's
plenty of people who
say [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up and i know and
there's times you and you've seen it
where you don't even get the
notification
like it doesn't even post it just it
doesn't it's never there yeah and then
and sometimes it'll get through and
you'll get a notification and it'll be
gone before you can read it but that
same person will come back an hour later
and go oh you're deleting comments and
it's like no i didn't even know you were
i only delete comments from people i
don't like um but youtube does that
sometimes people chinese
even if you say something nice about the
chinese communist party
so that's an algorithm that was deemed
by somebody at youtube or some people as
deemed derogatory toward chinese
50 cent party for whatever reason i came
i was uh you you you joined the party
for 50 cents it was something about that
but
there's a there's google was contacted
by the spectator of someone saying
asking for comments i haven't gotten
back to him yet but they've they noticed
that there were certain phrases it was
the verge by the way automatically
absolutely
problem is again now we're dealing with
sticky [ __ ] because they they're taking
a lot of [ __ ] for it so what but i do
agree that when it comes to
look i think if if a bunch of teenagers
a bunch of like well because we'd all
hear all those guys
i'm sorry
but this is this is ever this is every
fighter in the kid mike and i disagree
on things all the time and whatever but
we always try to respect each other
when we're talking we really do even if
we disagree we try to get the other
person at the point but go ahead let me
show you this entire show you're brian
collins
tell me a point tell me a point about
youtube right now start talking about a
point well you know they they do censor
yeah no it's crazy
it's because the
no sorry bro go ahead but yes so what
happens is they have an algorithm that
they've built in dopey i know dude no
but you're wrong
well then he just
thunk yeah exactly it's
shut up
hang it up on 112 year old we have to do
something about it and if it's cyber
it's bullying if you saw them doing it
in the school yards you'd be like hey
what the [ __ ] is this
i just won't let it by the way we do
interrupt each other sometimes sometimes
especially when we get fired up about
something but this is just
every time right like every time he
speaks
but he's not even interrupting with
something good yeah it's not like he's
passionate and he's going but no you're
right it's like
it's like what okay i guess
yeah well it's hard to combat it i guess
i guess you could block everybody
yeah i mean you as parents you have to
tell your kid like
there's a separation between like don't
take it seriously but as your kid you
can't then but you know what the problem
hey hey i know we asked you to come on
here but shut up bro shut up bro i like
my two brain cells just thought of
something i would have so i got to like
say something bro i would leave
like i know nobody's ever done that on
this show but like joel mchale should
have done that yeah joel mchale should
have just instead of laying on that
couch when they did that he should have
just got up and left it would have been
such a chat move
to just leave
like that would have been gangster as
[ __ ] i'd have been like oh snap joel
mchale just walk but that's another
problem with and this is why these
people are allowed to exist
everybody in la it's this big circle
jerk of agents
and managers and all these companies
that own people everybody has to be nice
to the guys that have the same
representation in them
it's this weird little inbred town
so even the people that don't like each
other have to pretend to like each other
and that's why they have no credibility
that's why nobody likes this l.a scene
say what you want about new york right
but you have somebody like jake flores
who comes out and basically [ __ ] and
moans and talks
a truckload of [ __ ] about louis jay
gomez openly and then luis jay gomez
sees him in a club and [ __ ] throws
his drink in his face and tries to fight
him but say what you want like maybe
that's not the best way to behave but
hey i respect those guys because they're
not doing a whole no no you know like
you're not seeing you're never going to
see louis jay gomez going oh no dog i
think jake flores is such a good comic
dude he's so nice brilliant dude we have
our differences but he's brilliant like
they don't do that it's like no no come
on back down to the stand i'm smacking
your [ __ ] mouth like i respect that
more like they're not hiding it these
guys literally they could have like
they could have the biggest falling out
in the world and they're gonna end with
like no look man you know whatever i
think he's brilliant i think he's a
brilliant guy i think he's awesome and
you're like you know you don't like him
you don't like him
most of these people out there don't
like tim dylan they don't but
if somebody told them hey this is one of
our guys now he's coming in be nice
right it's but there's people out there
that just don't like each other they
know most of them don't like shobb
i mean it's pretty obvious when you
bring them up a lot of them don't like
shop from first hand experience yeah
they'll never say it on a show
especially off the air you talk to
people everyone hates the guy yeah but
they're there's this weird like you're
like i don't want to [ __ ]
yeah i don't want to talk [ __ ] about the
guy you know he's a good dude you know
and it's like you just don't you don't
want rogan to [ __ ] find out and and
never let you on that's what it is
i mean just so new we don't know the
repercussions all we're seeing is
suicide rates super high we know some
celebrities suffer some super they they
suffer from depression because of the
comments they get
[Laughter]
i
i'm stunned people are such these people
all grow up in these hug boxes
stunned
celebrities
that are living in their multi-million
dollar mansions
that won't look you in the [ __ ] face
when you walk down the street
are hurting
because of something that they could
ignore
this is so funny they could just ignore
the comments right like nobody's
making them read them
just don't don't look out of them don't
look at them
the new cte we'll see what happens
well hold on what was that sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry look at the look
you should have seen that yeah but it's
right back up from depression because of
the comments they get
yeah this is like the new cte we'll see
what happens
we have friends
who've looked at look at that look at
this the moment of self realization on
his face do you like are you i'm sorry
i'm sorry but is indian ray romano
i don't know who he is is he comparing i
know people are going to who that studs
is [ __ ]
lock lock you should know him i don't
care
um
you implying
that mean comments on the internet are
equivalent to
traumatic brain injury
yeah somebody calling you a [ __ ] in
your youtube comments is the same as
literal brain damage
somebody calling you a [ __ ] in your
youtube comments it's just like getting
your brains smashed somebody has a
this is great uh right right like like
royce and merch could not care less
about the comments no i care about the
comments i read them
but i'm also not saying i'm not going to
i'm not going to kill myself over them
and i'm not implying be nice to me in
the comments are all cute i'll know i
swear to god i'll literally kill myself
i read them read the chat all the time
we try to read the chat comments we want
to know what people are saying sometimes
good sometimes bad
i get that but i'm not saying i'm not pr
i'm not pretending like your mean
comments are the new cte are you [ __ ]
kidding me right now
you've dealt with it and gone into deep
depressions just from the comments and
[ __ ] control yeah dude you know you put
something out there wait wait he's
personally dealt with this yeah it's
like dude and sometimes people will say
mean things in your youtube comments and
it's it's like literally being raped
fans who've who've dealt with it and
gone into deep depressions just from the
comments and [ __ ] control yeah dude you
know you put something out there rogan
always says just don't read the comments
yeah like i i know that's what i do man
i'm like really good at it but then
sometimes you need to slip or but it's
like do you want to dive into that pool
like you know what's there like very
rarely do you ever go into youtube
comments and you're like i feel great
i'm glad i did never i don't know i mean
that's not necessarily true i mean
sometimes i look i do look at her
youtube comments sometimes and when i do
there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] there's a
lot of people that hate us but there's a
lot of good stuff yeah i mean there's bo
i would say 50 50.
there's probably there's a lot of people
that don't like us and depending
especially depending on the topic if you
go after a certain fandom and also you
have to realize too is that the people
that are saying nice things about you
they're going to show up and they're
going to say one nice thing and they're
going to leave the people that hate you
are going to make 15 accounts and show
up at astroturf so it's like
you know what i mean when you see that
[ __ ] it's like okay i'm gonna it's like
people it's like guys to tell you how
many women they've been with i'm just
gonna divide that [ __ ] by ten because
you know you haven't you know what i
mean like it's it's it's always gonna be
like it's like the old expression people
don't call the store to say the milk was
good
most people who like you aren't going to
leave positive comments because they're
just going to like the video and go hey
whatever good the people that hate you
that there's way more emotional
investment in that and they're going to
make six accounts and go you're [ __ ]
better and then they're going to reply
to their own comments and go yeah i'm
with you you're all right and then log
back into the other account go yes you
are very smart thank you sir like it's
it's just weird
i want to do this sketchbook still had a
great bit on youtube comments oh i want
to do this one schedule where it's like
i'm saying it's like lord of the rings
i'm saying goodbye to my family at the
village like i have to go to the youtube
comments and then it's like
that's a great that's really funny
that's a good skit good stuff la comics
are trash garbage you're trash
you're a pile of [ __ ] [ __ ] did you
see the tim dillon thing where he
dressed up like the coronavirus that
went around no it was a great bit i
liked it the first time when he dressed
up like jeffrey epstein's temple and
went around that's the same bit that's
cool over and over again it's there's
something about the air in l.a maybe
it's the smog or the water you touch
down in la and you live there for two
days and you're automatically a hack
you know what you know you know what
this rogan crew is like this doesn't
this little rogue crew is like yeah well
you know what this rogue crew is like
is like the looters that's going on like
we said there's probably some good
protesters out there trying to do stuff
maybe there's good comics in l.a there
might be great ones there really might
be i mean that seriously there might be
great comics in l.a
but these guys astro turf everything
this is when you think of la comics you
could only think of this
the [ __ ] tight pants and the girl
shoes there are no good comics in la i'm
sorry that's like that's like watching
this riot footage and going you know
somewhere in that group of people
setting that target on fire there's a
future doctor
i've never i've never once read a
youtube comment no i've never have
either i don't really he's an expert on
people not getting banned for youtube
wait wait wait you said you've never
read a youtube comment but you just said
one minute ago literally 60 seconds ago
that sometimes
you give in and you do read the comments
because you just said rogan said not to
read the youtube comments and you go but
sometimes you slip so yeah you do
brenden you've admitted that you have
brandon don't lie
the problem is i have family members
that'll read them oh dude so i have
family to follow and they're like these
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm like hey i don't
want to care
my mom would call me you've watched our
videos making fun of you and commented
on them what are you talking about
she'd be like i saw you uploaded that
video did you read that one guy
x92 says
suck my dick
what do you want me to do mom yeah when
i was i was doing a shitty tv show one
time
with heaven which one
[ __ ] any show he's ever done
pick one name a good tv show he's done
that
but my uh my mother would read all the
comments uh she would read this is
before social media she would read the
critics
should read the critics and she'd be so
mad that she would write the critics
back a letter i'm like this is not oh
don't worry about it dude the critic
first vote is kind of right number one
number two relax that'll be funny the
critic right to retraction like after
being contacted
she made some good points you've been
doing so much work
it takes so much work to do this and
these they're so spiteful i'm like well
listen this is the business and they're
kind of right yeah you well maybe my dad
you got to stay out of commons man if
you if you aren't selling takes on the
road if you're not sold on the road no
one's watching a podcast and you don't
have a following instagram you're
getting hate on forever yeah and your
fans will follow you like the ones who
don't like you who gives a [ __ ] but like
you keep but again you can't read
comments but you said that you read
comment i can't with this guy
i i just i just can't
but i have to say this
people are getting to them which is real
you think so yeah they just did a
[ __ ] 10 minute 11 minute segment
where they didn't let their guests talk
because they were too busy talking about
the haters i'd say people are getting to
them
i'd say yeah people are getting to them
they're outside of their little hog box
and people are getting to them